on this day in 1989 Chinese tanks rolled
into Beijing's Tiananmen Square to crush
a student-led protest movement calling
for greater political freedom the death
toll remains in dispute but it is
believed thousands may have been killed
the iconic image of one man standing up
to the tanks became a worldwide symbol
of defiance Elizabeth Palmer returned to
tenement square 30 years later to find
its bloody history erased by modern
China CBS News headquarters in New York
here is Dan Rather good evening
thousands of combat troops from the
People's Liberation Army now occupy tnmn
square in Beijing the students are gone
they'd been there for weeks then on June
4th hardliners in the Communist Party
send in the army it was a bloodbath
hundreds maybe thousands were killed war
arc I see then 21 and one of the main
student leaders escaped I am a survivor
of a massacre I have to live with the
guilt he and the students knew the
government was threatened by demands for
reform real ammunition and tanks rolling
over people no way we visited Tiananmen
Square which is now a tourist attraction
under 24/7 surveillance every lamppost
supports a cluster of cameras and the
squares been completely scrubbed of
anything that might recall the events of
1989 it happened in the state in fact
the government has so successfully
written them out of history no idea that
random young people we asked didn't even
recognize the most famous gentleman
picture is in which country Communist
Party is extremely nervous about people
learning and the the fact of what
happened which is people stood and
the government to make sure they never
did it again the party introduced
sweeping economic changes that transform
China into a dynamic power but at its
core it remains an authoritarian police
state we failed
let's face it they are exchanging our
economic freedom with our political
freedom mukashi the young idealist paid
a personal price you were there he spent
the next three decades in exile I
haven't been able to see my parents for
the last 30 years I cannot go back to
China and they denied them traveling
abroad
that's quite a price to pay I'm
heartbroken for that and heartbroken for
the reform movement one so full of hope
now utterly crushed for CBS this morning
I'm Elizabeth Palmer in Beijing before
it's just a stunning state it's amazing
that in this day and age with the way
information can travel so quickly that
that image essentially has been
obliterated indeed